in a completely kind of random turn of
events Donald Trump the guy who's all
about military spending is now saying
that our military spending is crazy
that's a quote after complaining for so
long about President Obama being weak on
the military about President Obama not
spending enough on the military Donald
from tweeted yesterday that too much is
being spent on the military saying quote
I am certain that at some time in the
future President Xi and I together with
President Putin of Russia will start
talking about a meaningful halt to what
has become a major and uncontrollable
arms race the United States spent 716
billion dollars this year crazy now
there's a few layers to this that I want
to talk about the first being that
Donald Trump previously bragged about
how he's spending more on the military
and talked about how great it is that
he's doing that one example from Twitter
Trump saying quote because of the seven
hundred seven hundred and sixteen
billion dollars gotten to rebuild our
military many jobs are created in our
military is again rich building a great
border wall with drugs poison and enemy
combatants pouring into our country is
all about National Defense build wall
through military one other example from
Donald Trump where he said quote got 1.6
billion to start wall on southern border
rest will be forthcoming most
importantly got 700 billion to rebuild
our military 716 billion next year most
ever had to waste money on dem giveaways
in order to take care of military pay
increase and new equipment Trump
proposed spending 716 billion on the
military in February Trump
bragged about how great it is to be
spending 716 billion on the military and
now he's denouncing that we're spending
716 billion on the military so there's a
few hypotheses here number one is
cognitive decline just plain and simple
evidence of cognitive decline number two
this is Trump getting erratic because
he's so afraid as the walls closing
around him based on everything that
we've been talking about on the program
leading up to you today
number three hypothesis is that
something happened at the g20 in
Argentina someone at the g20 suggested
to him that he say this or suggested to
him that maybe this is something he
could work on with Putin in the future
like maybe it was Putin himself who said
the Trump you know it's really crazy how
the United States is spending so much
money on the military and then all of a
sudden Donald Trump tweets about it
because it definitely seems like this is
an idea that would come from somebody
like Vladimir Putin Trump criticizing
military budget increases while enacting
and bragging about and cheering military
budget increases Trump increased the
military budget by nearly 25 percent in
two years and now he says that the
military budget is out of control this
may be sort of like a childlike salep
sister m-- object permanence this is
like when a little kid covers their eyes
they sometimes don't understand that
just because they cover their eyes and
they can no longer see you you can still
see them and this relates to the
psychological concept of object
permanence things still exist even when
you can't see them or you can't perceive
them it's almost Pat like some deranged
adult version that is manifesting where
Trump says hey I'll just talk about how
military spending is out of control and
nobody will be able to see the fact that
I've been tweeting and bragging about
military spending for the last couple of
years well it certainly doesn't make
sense from a contradiction standpoint
for him to say that but also he's making
it sound as though we're spending 716
billion dollars and Russia and China are
right behind us that they're right in
there with the arms race
not at all I mean we always hear about
how the US spends more than the next
eight countries and defense spending
combined or the next ten countries and
defense spending combined I just I don't
really understand what the impetus was
for this tweet I mean maybe it does have
to do with the g20 but like you could
have said this all along that's what's
very strange about it and it's the
timing that is making me wonder what the
hell is going on and along those lines I
have sort of like one more hypothesis to
present to you which is a little bit
more involved than the ones I've
mentioned so far let's imagine that
Donald Trump realizes that at some point
he's gonna have to make a call about
whether the United States gets involved
in Ukraine or not because as you may
remember Russia's aggression against
Ukraine has been increasing they rammed
a Ukrainian Navy vessel they took and
haven't returned at least as at the last
time that I looked some Ukrainian Navy
sailors almost every other Western
country has come out in defense of
Ukraine if you're Trump and you are
realizing that at some point you might
have to say we're going to get involved
with our allies in defending Ukraine or
we're not what about the possibility of
laying the groundwork now for saying you
know what we can't afford to get
involved to help Ukraine because we're
spending so much on the military just
like I tweeted after the g20 is that
type of forethought possible for Trump I
think so and you know this is why he
takes every possible position on every
possible issue because people can just
pick and choose his comments well he or
he said that he wants more defense
spending and here he says he wants less
defense spending so you can just pick
and choose what fits your political
ideology and that's what his supporters
do to be super clear I agree with Trump
that military spending is out of control
I don't want to pretend like all of a
sudden now that Trump says it it's not
what I believe I agree with him it's
just he's almost always tweeting the
opposite of this sentiment and I'm
trying to figure out what is it that's
going on here what do you think is going
on let me know I want to hear from you